hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are at game 2 of
our match Magnus Carlsen versus Fabiana
Caruana
in game 1 a Magnus one death brilliant
victory in the aliens defense and now
it's far-eastern to perhaps retaliate
with the black pieces to get back into
the match so without further ado let's
check it out
Magnus witted the white pieces opens for
d4 so a sticks width would be usual
doesn't doesn't change anything Knight
f6 we've c4 e6 Knight to f3 and the
Queens gambit declined Fabi doesn't go
for for anything crazy
we have Knight to c3 and now not going
for the for the other goes in that we've
seen a scene so a lot lately actually
but rather just D captures and c4 yeah
so so sort of a post except accepting
the gambit
we have III and just opening up the
bishops diagonal to recapture the pawn
with a 6 and now a for stopping b5 we
have c5 by black and now recapturing
Bishop captures on c4 and we have Knight
to c6 and the castles by Magnus C
captors on d4 we recapture Sundy for
ended Bishop to e7 Fabi now prepares the
castle and Magnus continues developing
with Bishop to e3 and now castles that's
not a castles and castles and now Knight
to e5 by Magnus just putting a night or
two a nice central outpost whereas if
black captures it then this point will
be very strong here later you will
support it with f4 and you will just
grab a lot more space so far being
reluctant to go for this trade we have
Bishop to d7 and now there are a few
games in the database where a wife
continued with Queen to e2 connected
rooks got got the rooks into the game
but here Magnus just eliminates the
bishop and he decides that this is this
is good enough for him with the white
pieces for a rapid game against Fabi
the idea is simply Queen captures and
the d5 and here Magnus just trades
everything so it's a capture fast
capture scout Chris Knight characters
with Queen Castor's Queen captures and
Bishop captures and now Magnus trades
down into this in game where he has two
bishops against a bishop in the night
well of course n2 roofs so Bishop to f6
going after the b2 pawn and Magnus
simply develops the d1 rook F to D 1 if
this pawn is captured then this row
comes to be one goes after the b7 pawn
so rook F to be 8 by Fabi and King to f1
Magnus starts bringing the King into the
game rook d7 prepares to double up on
the D file and now Bishop to f3 Magnus
wants to trade both of the rooks we rook
a to d8 and now just rook captures on b7
rook captures and now rook the c1 just
putting pressure on the night here
preparing the character and win this
pawn go after the a6 pawn still not
interested in this pawn you just wrote
rook to be 1 or or if Bishop captures
even better just Bishop captures and c6
right away as this also attacks the rook
here
so instead after Luke the c1 we have
looked at d6 now adding a defender to
the night here on c6 and Magnus just
continues pushing with b4 now if pawn
captures then the should capture Sun b7
so we have g5 by Fabi
starts his expansion and the King side
and now comes work the c5 now puts
pressure under the g5 pawn and now a
Fabi should either place unlike h6 but
then he goes into b5 which is also not
that great for black so instead he
decides the trade so Knight captures and
before and now before recapturing first
rook to see a twit check and here Bobby
Bobby blocks with the rook rook to b8
if you go King to g7 then Bishop to c5
is incredibly strong so you have to
trade the rooks here as well even though
trading rooks is not really going in
fabi's favor
so rook b8 we have rook captures Bishop
captures and only now Bishop captures
and b7 and now we have this well to
bishops against the bishop and the night
with wit pawns on both sides of the
board that means of course the side with
the bishop pair is to be favored so King
g7 Bobby starts bringing the key
Internet King into the game King to e 2
we have a 5 now so the bishop guards it
there you can start doing stuff with
your Knight and King d2 and now Magnus
wants to shift this King all the way
here play Bishop to b6 get the
this bishop and we'll just gobble up da
five phone with his King
so f5 by Fabi and now just came to see
three we have came to have six and King
to see for Bishop the c7 attacking the
h3 pawn but now just h3 and g4 by Fabi
King the b5 by Magnus now Bishop to b5
Bishop to b6 is unstoppable
King to e5 and now first H captures on
g4 with F captures and now Bishop to b6
and now the pawn Falls there is there's
no defending this pawn king these six
but now Bishop captures on c7 with King
captures now of course you cannot
capture as the bishop is hanging so
Bishop the e4 are going after this pawn
as well so h5 but now King captures on
a5 and now the problem is the knight is
attacked and this bishop really covers
all of the squares the knight can use of
course you do not want the trade as
White has an extra pawn but it would be
interesting since this point is also
very close for example if Knight to c6
can wipe trade if Bishop character
screen captures now where do you go for
example yeah you don't have to go
anywhere g3 just stops all contra place
but from black soul yeah there's also
that white is the first to move so night
the a - that ID only square that's left
and now comes g3 so preventing this h4
idea for for fob it also try to create a
pass bone and the H file Knight to c3
getting the night into the game and not
night the c2 we have nice to eat you buy
Fabi and here Magnus played Bishop to g6
and it was also in this position on move
40 that Fabiano Caruana resigned the
game and the game 2 also goes to Magnus
which is which is an excellent start
two against two against Oh which two two
more games so far be now has to win two
games on demand which is a terrible
place to be if you're playing against
world champion Magnus Carlsen so here of
course you resign you still have your a
point and now Bishop is just gonna
gobble up these pawns they are on light
squares so not much to do for this night
completely reasonable but it's just
amazing how I'm pretty sure Magnus had
this prepared all of this at home after
he played night at five and Bobby did
not care
or something like that people in Bishop
to d7 how simple it is just characters
captures and now into this capture phase
that we mentioned and you just play this
end game with the bishop pair against
the bishop at night but you also have to
be very strong to be able to do that
strap after Bishop g65 will resigned and
yet another victory for Magnus Carlsen
so that's Game two of their match I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank William McKay Gavin crook Joe
labrum abajo Lane Market and bark cuts
here for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thankful for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnuson
rotational until it finishes so thank
you I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day